Google Friend Connect is a free product that
lets site owners of any experience level personalize
their website in ways that help their visitors
connect and get to know each other.
Getting started is simple: log in to your
account at www.google.com/friendconnect, enter
your website information, and you're ready
to add Friend Connect features to your website.You
can start with the Friend Connect gadget gallery
where you'll find a range of social features--
from letting users post comments to letting
them rate and review content-- that you can
add to your site by simply selecting some
customization options, and then copying and
pasting snippets of HTML code.
Let's take a closer look at some of the Friend
Connect features on this guitar website.
Here's the members gadget. It lets people
join your site with existing logins from Google,
Yahoo, and others, meet other members, send
private messages, and invite others to join,
either by sending an email or by sharing your
website on services like Twitter and Facebook.
You can encourage visitors to share relevant
details about themselves by adding questions
to the 'Interests' section of your account.
Users can answer these questions when joining
your website or via the poll gadget, and the
answers they share are made publicly available
on their Friend Connect profile, making it
easy for people with similar interests to
find each other. Their responses also appear
in your account in easy-to-read charts, and
you can export this data for use with other
services at anytime.The details users share
allow you to personalize your website based
on member's interests.
Like having your site pages that are most
relevant to people's interests automatically
display in the featured content gadget.
Or displaying ads that are targeted to both
your website's content and visitors' interests
through Google AdSense.
Or letting users subscribe to interest-based
newsletters that you can create, send, and
manage all from within your Friend Connect
account.
There's a lot more you can do with Google
Friend Connect, but we'll leave the rest for
you to discover. Get started today at www.google.com/friendconnect.